so we're celebrating fourth of july
early as you may have just heard they're
eating hot dogs that's a tradition for a
lot of folks on independence day the
barbecue
mmm gotta do it yeah this morning we're
stopping by american coney island at
fremont street to find out
how we can step up our game when it
comes to those dogs
hector mejia live in downtown with the
details hector where's your hat
hey there so i had to take a little bit
of a break from that hat but here is one
of the hot dogs here and it's like
raining hot dogs here at american coney
island
and we're learning how to make the best
hot dog on earth especially with
fourth of july coming up in just a few
days joining us here we have general
manager mario to tell us
all right just about how many people are
you guys expecting for this crowded
weekend oh it should be packed this
weekend guys
uh welcome back and uh we're looking for
a great turnout
so with this giant party plan in vegas
this weekend you know a lot of
restaurants including this one are
preparing to host
thousands of people and here we have uh
some hot dogs here
tell us how can we make the best hot dog
and end up with
something really delicious uh simple
guys chili mustard onions
on a natural casing hot dog
is there a perfect ratio maybe not too
much mustard or maybe not too much chili
or is that
really not such a thing you don't want
to overpower with the mustard
uh just a little bit on the mustard and
then we uh you know
the hot dog is the showcase item there
and then the chili
and the onions for a little bit of taste
perfect so we're also
profiling american coney island the
company been around for more than 100
years
yes 104 years in business family owned
and operated out of detroit michigan
uh here in las vegas uh since 2012
at the d las vegas and how long here
along fremont street
one more time how long have you guys
been here along three months 2012 is
when we first came out uh when the d
opened up all right so keeping it pg
what's one of the craziest
uh stories you've seen here along
fremont street um gotta ask i mean you
see it all
this place is open 24 hours yeah
sometimes you know we see some stuff we
want to see some stuff we don't want to
see
but it's all in good fun you know you
guys were busy here
earlier as soon as we all we when we got
here there was a guy that walked in he
was like what do you say he said
i'm from minneapolis we're like hey sir
we're about to go live in just a few
seconds
uh well being that you know it's the
tourism capital of the world everybody
wants to stay where they're from and uh
we love it
come on down looking forward to fourth
of july definitely
absolutely yeah happy fourth everyone
and uh looking forward to
you know serving everyone and uh with
our delicious product
thank you sir so uh there you go uh you
know i actually ate a couple of hot dogs
so i'm gonna
take a break but i believe this is next
some delicious chili cheese fries
i think i need some extra cheese though
i love that extra cheese on my chili
cheese fries
back to you guys that's animal style
right there oh yeah
oh man oh it sure is
it's all part of a well-balanced
breakfast hector thank you very much uh
the staffs there seem energized ready to
go this morning yeah absolutely
in fact he he needs to tone it down that
yeah he's a little bit a little bit over
the top
dial it back a little bit thanks hector
appreciate that sir
it is it's that time right fourth of
july your hot dogs your hamburgers your
barbecues it's just it's part of what
you do it is
hector put those in a to-go bag by the
way please don't forget
i need a chili dog right so some friends
called to ask if we want to come over
and and
ciao with them on sunday right and they
were like uh well we're thinking about
doing a barbecued
would you rather have hamburgers yeah
and i was like burgers are good
and then they texted again so would you
rather do ribs i was like ribs are
really good so yes please okay
so no more burgers burgers are out well
if they're gonna give us the option
which one would you choose yeah